I know that you go to Disneyland
sometimes entertain yes and it's such a
great place actually I I do believe
that's a place where the grown-ups have
a good time the kids have a good time
and I'm not saying that I'm not getting
any money from them they put a chip in
my head years ago but it's not me
but do you enjoy going there yeah
because I cuz I get a guide so we don't
wait in line right why would I not enjoy
it that's it's expensive but then the
guy it's expensive yeah it's worth it
yeah I mean it's you know it can be very
crowded but you know what they have it's
so the California side California side
is adventure California Adventure booze
yeah what they have food and wine and
beer margarita everything so our guide
was like you know you should probably
make reservations and we have like a
fine dining restaurant over there and we
go to this place and it's really nice
the food's really good and the waitress
just kept saying I'm gonna bring you
more booze
because you're gonna need it that's very
crowded on the other side today and so
they just she just kept going like no I
was like no I'm actually fine she's like
I'm bringing you another one I'm like
okay so okay you just get that you know
and you can look around the whole
restaurant it's just all the parents the
Pirates in the appearance of the
Caribbean ride I was like 97 degrees
that day so you know everyone was just
like help me through this yeah it's a
grape I love going there and it's like
oh that's that's an eye-opener to me the
next time I'm there with my kids I'm
gonna make my way to the California
Adventure side yeah and you and Andy you
weren't seemed very familiar with no yet
available no no we go to I mean as a
family we live 45 minutes from
Disneyland we go there we have season
passes like an hour
oh no well but but you know yeah but I
mean if you go to you against traffic
it's not so far and we and there's
people all the time we were like god it
seems like you go there like three or
four times a year and I'm like well yeah
it's Disney like make it easy
yeah it's Disneyland yeah but I didn't
know you could drink that adds a whole
Rico for me papa don't check the
contents of those Camelback things
either you can just load it up on your
back you know I went through the it's a
small world ride once and I was pretty
sure I saw Andy sleeping behind the
little ball I tried and he just in the
corner once you get used to the song you
can sleep
you